[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c est patrick sébastien qui s'est payé
ici ça ne l'est pas ça s'arrête jamais
bien sûr mais d'amour directeurs des
collèges a cessé mes fringues à moi j'ai
même plus le temps de passer aux joies
dormi avec il repart de cartes est en
train de bousculer les codes là sur
virgin radio là on arrête pas aux 7
heures à 10 heures mahdavi dans quatre
heures ou alors les bras coquilles et on
garde de virgin radio c'est que voulait
absolument qu'ils reviennent l'année
prochaine entre 7h et 10h sur virgin
radio
est-ce que tu as une déclaration leur
faire je n'en serai pas éclater et
cartonne aussi très content d'être en
temps mais après il faut aussi là on est
en train de prendre 40 en deux ans là
bas
anon là je vais me lève d'un bond quand
josé lama tient sur la tête de ma mère
c'est un des bons mois en deux ans je
ressemblais enrico macias que j'aime
beaucoup
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
giulia il a cartonné il a fait trois ans
mercy binta tron 4 4 ans et vahid
affiche cas les os et ouais les gars
s'est élevé à quelle heure lever à 5h du
mat en mairie mais je me couche à des
battues peut y aller parce que moi je
suis libre dont je me fiche totalement
filets mignons ils ont juste si les
fringues 10 ans en fait
la protoss maman acer et ses chroniques
as exclusive à menzel espagnol je suis
donc à sa delta pélagiques moralement
par bérenger le riz coûte une taille et
pour commencer avec les 24 ans et c'est
tout ce qu'il fallait pas manquer sur
les écrans alors tant attendu juste
avant les 24 antennes et je voudrais
saluer ses mythes il ya un film énorme
ce soir tu as well juste après x-men
x-men 2 c'est incroyable alors ils sont
très forts ses huit passes pour regarder
comment ils écrivent hugh jackman il
écrit hugh jackman s'est gaufré google
ont rendu ces fronts le garçon et
connaît les x men de nous ça alors ils
vont mettre mais nan demander à quoi bon
aller votre cas tenter voulait voir au
sein du risque gros oui c'est un
plébiscite mais bon comme il y en a
beaucoup que ce qui s'est passé à peine
deux heures j'ai gardé leur ip de
l'émission la robe de ma vie où des
femmes choisissent la robe de mariée de
leurs rêves
visiblement les mariés qu'à femmes et
pas du tout qui sait saint aubin c'est
une manière de l'investir
la réalité c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
[Musique]
alors
/
à 6 heures je me suis refait 1re div de
capital on a trouvé le nom du gars
d'ailleurs qu'il faut jamais passé aux
toilettes dessert à perte 2 voici
sébastien bouge tous vos copains fleurs
sur ce tapis chat et bien même jean
marie le pen le même maintenant pour
saisine perdu on a pu le vérifier dans
le trésor des formes si c'est un garage
désaffecté kenavo solide qui s'appelle
fille non pas dans légion il ya un
attrait dessus ce qui nous a montré
comment prendre un escalator quand il
est bondé
c'est fort et fo du gainage ans
solide
non
d'ailleurs
rendre venir juste avant de venir c'est
enfin arrivé si reed et kenji ont eu un
enfant de stars ensemble on a la photo
et ça c'est fait oui
[Applaudissements]
sadio bah c'est pas quoi penser de la
sorte
est ce que je chantais ce que je dis des
conneries je sais par le gars se cherche
mais j'aime bien on a testé l'état je
loue à l'aube
bon j'ai regardé jean pierre pernaut
aujourd'hui je rêve de le rencontrer
jean-pierre pas je suis un an je reste
devant le jt de 13 heures j'ai toujours
voulu poser la question que tout le
monde envie de poser un grand
journaliste comme lui qui a passé plus
de 20 ans à la tête du trésor
est ce qu'ils mangent avant ou après son
jt ça m'en fous cette question ce qu'ils
mangent ce gars à mon avis ça dépend ce
moment c'est avant il ya une petite
goutte de calva dans le café à mon avis
s'ils passent tous nos maux jean-pierre
des fois il ya les amarres à ce moment l
accusé qui passe ça commence avec une
sortie de route en voulant placer le
moteur justement on l'a aperçu tout à
l'heure sur l'autoroute a13 perdre ou
alors c'est aussi un grand concours sur
les marchés donc il appelle les gens à
voter pour élire le plus beau marché et
je pense que je suis pas sûr qu'ils
aient compris de l'esa jours est un peu
plus d'une semaine pour voter m'occupe
des evaux aux antilles notamment
mais le meilleur c'est sur le nombre
sont journalistes savent eux mêmes plus
rien dire la nationale 118 est restée
fermée vous le savez pas ce que ça
montre
côté circulation va faire un petit point
avec patrick tine est particulier
c'est marrant j'ai déjà entendu ce bruit
quelque part
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi jean pierre léaud fiche
il n'a pas les vidéos fiches donc ya pas
les bonnes lunettes on s'amuse à lui
mettre la bonne terre c'est gratos ou le
trophée andros de courses automobiles
sur place comment je t'aime prochaine
[Applaudissements]
j'adore comme sais de quoi tu vas pas
rire tu vois le prompteur
ouais je vois ouais bah j'ai encore et
encore moins deux c'est mieux
on commence avec d'autres font appel les
niches en corée avec les jurys lundi
versailles à l'automne déjà un beau
parce qu on est évidemment pour l'équipe
de france bien sûr mais on a une
nouvelle souci c'est maxi c'est la seule
skieuse de fond du togo on a plaisanté
avec kelleher a été seul à la cérémonie
d'ouverture
eh bien nous regarder depuis le village
olympique elle nous a fait un bisou non
mais elle avait noté elle regarde tes
paix une paix depuis la cour et depuis
le village olympique
non mais voilà on a bien fait de la
saluer à écouter
l'entente ou trois gars coups de recul
ah ouais mais pau d'ousse baudet me away
alors moi c'est pas mon délire mais la
très jolie mais jamais rien parce que
moi mais les mots d'el harrouch années
mais elle est invitée à son retour des
gis on arrive tout de suite à son retour
des jets à huy apparemment vous êtes en
contact avec elle
l'innovation n'est en twitter quoi ça
swingue ça faisait sur le dos de près ou
de loin pas du tout mais celle qui nous
a salués pas du tout je suis rangé des
bayod de voix votes m'offre regarde
l'émission est ce que vous avez dit on
parler d eux tout à l'heure ce que vous
avez vu de la délégation norvégienne
s'est trompée qui voulait commander 1500
dreux ils ont mal manipulé le traducteur
google et du coup ils ont vu arriver
15000e alors sur les vannes plus de 60
plus de 80 85 ans cette clé le matin sur
rtl on aime beaucoup la stia
voulait tenter et après mon rôle va me
la kiffer la vibe
c'est cocasse le mot c'est que j'aime
bien mattila c'est à cet incident mais
vraiment dior ne fait pas plus belle je
moi ouais ouais mais tu ne t'es pas sur
nous c'est tout ce qu'on vous diront oui
et puis je vois isabelle depuis le début
de la chronique
elle fait ça go qui connaît pas les jo
après la victoire de martin fourcade ya
laurent luyat c'est normal marocaine
médaillé d'or troisième médaille or ça
incroyable il a voulu recevoir sur son
plateau problème c'est qu'ils n'ont
personne pour chauffer le public là-bas
pays l'ont pas de public non plus
d'ailleurs
du coup quand tu reçois martin fourcade
bah tu as l'impression que tu reçois
françois fourcade comptable la journée
vincent jay est tout de suite donc
honneur au champion
voici martin fourcade
bravo martin obama tu es le hockey sur
glace aura dire aux consultants
québécois de france télé qu ici nos
ronds noirs on appelle ça un palais
parce que sinon on peut penser à autre
chose devant la téloche
le geste est dans ce cas là elle le fait
exprès d'un affluent du moto qui en fait
se baisse pour voir où est la rondelle
mettre la rondelle dans le filet
rappelez-vous hier patrick montel nous
avait prouvé qu'il est très doux en
pronostics
il reconnaît les champions patoche 1
attention à lui valait très loin kouba
qui aujourd'hui on s'est aperçu qu'il
est aussi père bon ton voir ce qu'ils
ratent là qu'on fait des corons pas de
médaille il a du flair norvégienne de
lillehammer a tiré en l'air mais ça
passe à droite
je pense qu'elle espérait un peu mieux
quand même oh là là prend la première
place semble
[Applaudissements]
ça va être ça cet autre owning sublime
et sa j'adore
c'est sublissime ça c'est que ça que ça
s'est assez bref il nous fait des
petites d ixia je pense qu'ils regardent
de la dent il adore des carters rennes
avait d'autres choses aussi
cabu qatar cartilage a encore plus des
jo que le pathos lui-même a aujourd'hui
épreuves de slopestyle connaissez sans
snowboard training slopestyle s'est dit
voilà il ya des barrières il ya des
bosses tous à une épreuve on tombe
beaucoup et les commentateurs ont le
même type pour commenter toutes les
chutes forcément puisqu'il y à la finale
de ce club style et je crois que nous
avons des mauvaises nouvelles 3,6 petit
conseil encore pour les journalistes
quand on parle de slopestyle
c'est important de dire le style sinon
tu dis que l'esprit jo il a changé un
côté de sa finale hier en finale n'a pas
eu la gagne et les x games en slope
lucas selon lui les consultants il a
pris les cons anglais donc il traduit
même ce qu'on aurait pu comprendre le
basson lui finalement de mouvements de
terrain et là on rentre dans la loi
comme vale vale du dragon merci et je
sais pas ce qui se passe au village
olympique mais les soirées ont l'air
sympa ces cadeaux je vais d'abord à leur
trouver là ça va ça va faire du bien
mauvaise activistes en fin de soirée les
moustiques les gens vont voir j'en fais
jamais de pegasis yafei a rejeté dakar 4
oct humaines en mer des eaux là bas bon
le problème que ce qui se passe quand on
regarde les jo c'est gagne tous les
épreuves
tu finis par type r d des épreuves tout
temps tout les jours et sur france télé
aussi je crois que c'est plus simple de
devenir biathlètes que de comprendre
quand passent les épreuves de biathlon
le prochain rendez-vous d'ailleurs bien
plomb avec lui ce sera quand messieurs
mercredi sur le 20 km
non je pense qu'il ya la lentille on est
là mais pardon c'est un jeudi ses
centres à midi pile mais midi pile
maintenant je me dis là 14 février et
jeudi 6 6 et jeudi 15 à midi pour les
garçons c'est bien c'est celle où
commençait vraiment c'était du lourd
aujourd'hui 1 et mathieu on va passion
tu es et tu passes captées avec du lourd
mesdames et messieurs s'il vous plaît et
on va regarder la médaille d'or de
martin fourcade le record du monde de
saut à skis a été battu avec du lourd
mesdames et messieurs s'il vous plaît
avec du curling c'est la finale et on
s'est rendu compte en parlant de curling
quand tu regardes situe mais d'autres
voix de si tu peux croire que c'est une
pub pour le m6 boutique en fait il se
propose bien sûr d'apprécier de nouveau
nos stations et regarder la vitesse et
l'efficacité du valais plus dans ce
genre de situation vous pouvez
l'utiliser partout
il retient toutes les saletés rapidement
efficacement et sans effort il ne laisse
absolument aucune trace vous allez faire
de sacrées économies qu'elles répondent
se régale donc à lui après m'avoir mis
au jour ces règles d'or mais c'est
étonnant mais c'est ouf fêté à l'antenne
je crois pas c'est mercredi
oui je dis ça mais confondent entre les
hommes les femmes et sept hommes sont
des méchants
oui travailler je suis un mot amour
encore au dictionnaire
merci mais non merci gens ordinaires
cette spontanéité
j'avais le père étrangères aussi ou à
des bio expekt vous connaissez marc hia
black m qui m'appelle 1 1 d'accord elle
n'a ni la conférence je peux te rappeler
après l'émission seront demain il a une
galère
en guerre bon alors vous connaissez
marque nouveau de l'arep de la rédac du
rtl belgique l'envoyant duplex d'un
carnaval et pas de bol il est tombé
livres 120 rôle ou pas oui le style en
refaisant away ou ses gestes j'en ferais
bien 120 relou j'avais pas fait l'udc au
carnaval et historique avec ses
personnages 14 personnages historiques
dans la célèbre bague est de mal mais de
quel est votre rôle dans ce carnaval
malin on attend entre quinze et vingt
mille personnes quant à moi vous pouvez
le voir je ne sais pas si petite auberge
en belgique cette fois ils ont leurs
pagaies eux c'est un journaliste comment
du terrain peut-être un petit peu trop
au bord ou alors c'est que les joueurs
de foot peuvent pas l'encadrer
[Musique]
comme ailleurs
vous pouvez bien tu mets mon moment
préféré c'est le remplaçant derrière son
coach qui se rend compte trop tard
qu'ils obtiennent mettre un slip ça
arrive aux meilleurs coûts cachés et
fatigue n'est pas du tout d'abord
victoire il se régale des terrains nus
ce qui veut dire j'ai envie de connaître
ça dans la gueule stud on encore un peu
de temps à 10 voitures l'otan pour le
talent j'ai regardé des chiffres et des
lettres aussi une sorte de qu'ils m'ont
acculée alors normalement on sait que
l'émission elle est hyper bien régler
ces gens vraiment comme du papier à
musique comme du papier à musique
millimétré mais cet après midi micro qui
restait pour cocher aussi se disent les
candidats à lolo pendant les jingle qui
fait semblant de rien entendre tu as tu
peut pas rattraper
on va pas tout expliquer j'ai mon petit
déjà bon allez c'est mignon dans cette
avenue de réalisons suivi un maître
nageur dans un parc aquatique est là
pour vérifier que tous les toboggans
sont en bon état et tu peux avoir
l'impression d'être dans le mal de la
santé prédigéré dans l'estomac ici il
arrive ensuite dans l'intestin grêle
ça arrive dans le côlon où sont formés
les selles ouais et surtout elle semble
garder on à la future mariée qu'elle
prête pour l'émission 4 mariages pour un
séjour c'est des angles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai pas forcément compris pourquoi une
marseillaise
je crois que ça va merci chanter la
marseillaise pour moi la marseillaise et
la sésamie rajeunie et bac jeudi soir
camille combal et de mort face à la
folie ma région et je suis envahi
plaisir je suis pas là vous leur faites
soulèvent cadets
[Applaudissements]